she love is not some victory mark
oh no I'm getting really sad too you
can't cry right sorry I'm sorry I
couldn't watch it
Misha Barton and Rachel Bilson in tears
watching back Marissa Cooper's death
scene on the OC okay I'm gonna get help
okay
yeah
that's how Marissa's described she's uh
she's definitely an interesting girl
next door she's got a lot going on for
your next door neighbor the emotional
trip down memory lane happened on the
welcome to the OC [ __ ] podcast where
Rachel and Misha's on-screen OC mom
Melinda Clark rewatch old episodes of
the Teen drama series it was Misha's
first time on the show it's been so long
we're coming up on the 20th anniversary
of the show which is insane like that's
wild yeah I'm like I could not feel
older if I tried yeah so of course they
watched the shocking third season moment
with Marissa herself I don't
particularly want to but I will I feel
you I'm with you I don't want to it is
so hard to watch it's true the ladies
couldn't hold back their tears oh no no
in the beautiful then the music
Hallelujah
I have chills all over my body no no
foreign
biggest tear jerker the flashback wait
what is this next bit you know him and
Sandy just flashes back to where you
guys meet each other yes
I can't you guys like okay yeah let's
not go there just like getting to do all
the different things with Marissa I mean
like we go on locations doing really
cool stuff like we filmed like the
Tijuana stuff on the Backlot at
Universal also we have a great crew so I
think we're very lucky for that Misha
made her big debut when the OC premiered
in 2003 that she quickly became a fan
fave who are you
whoever you want me to be
okay but fast forward to 2006 Marissa
was killed off which came as a shock
[Music]
me up in here before
I've seen this room and I've walked this
floor yeah Misha says if her character
was going out the moment needed to be
big it was like more blood more blood it
needs to because it was gonna border on
like being like a TV death and I really
wanted it to be super dramatic and real
as realistic as you can get for the OC
you know what I mean so like so that
people really like she went out with a
bang the show ended the year after
Misha's exit and as far as an OC reboot
goes well the actress has an idea on how
to bring herself back into the franchise
I think there are ways it could happen
for sure I mean in this industry there's
a way to do everything I mean if you
really want to get POC back up and
running of course we could like of
course there's a way yeah I mean
characters can like slightly change or
diverge
because there's so many million
different ways to rewrite something and
and retell the same story in a slightly
different way
[Music]